uh we do have a guest with us who won
his game oh that's the game actually you
have Daniel TARTA congratulations on
your win thank you thank you um so it
looks like you had a very smooth Victory
please take us through the game
okay C4 C5
um I checked a couple of things but here
after E3
um he played Bishop G7 I mainly checked
positions after a knight of six D4 takes
takes D5
and here like you have a completely
different game but he kind of um went
for a different move order he went
Bishop G7 which allowed me to go D4
straight away grab the center take
stakes and he played the Knight of six
so
um if I were to go Knight F3 now black
would go D5 and you get a very big line
that I hadn't really checked before the
game
so I was trying to make use out of the
fact that you went for a different move
order and he doesn't get D5 straight
away so I went D5 myself here it made
some sense to me during the game uh here
he went Castle Knight of three
and uh D6 but uh during the game to be
honest I was thinking I was more well
not really scared but I was thinking he
should have gone for E6 instantly
instead of these six yes because that uh
that didn't give me uh the option that I
had in the game so in the game he went
D6 basically uh und6 with black yeah I
played Bishop E2 and he went E6
well after Castle he would take D5 let's
say and after C takes D5 we would get
some symmetrical position like Castle Ed
CD and the position is quite balanced
right
and this is what he was aiming for
uh but he gave me the option that I
could take D takes E6 now okay and your
point is if he will go C6 here and you
take you can just take it yeah exactly
and now Knight C6 and black has a very
nice uh center right so
um yeah I assume that he was afraid that
I would push D6 myself yeah that was
gonna be my next question
yeah but maybe he has some uh some
strange ideas like maybe even a queen
somewhere Queen A5 or queen B6 but also
exactly yeah or B6 immediately and
Bishop B7 and develop his pieces
straight away
and uh it's not clear to me whether my
Pawn on D6 is such a strength or a
liability like it can be targeted in the
future I think
yeah it's really hard to determine these
things
I use quite some time but at the end I
went for detex E6 actually because uh I
think it's
well the position that I got in the game
looks very pleasant to me after a bishop
takes Knight D4 important move because
Castle's black has the option to play D5
and he gets rid of his weakness
so I went Knight D4
he went rookie eight um yeah probably a
good move because if you were to go
Knight C6 I would take the bishop and
then castle and black has these hanging
pawns which looks a bit uh weak and
strange also because white has the
bishop pair
so rookie 8 I castled first at Knight C6
and I took the bishop
Rook takes and this is also quite nice
for you right with the bishop here yeah
I thought during the game um well I
understood him I underestimated his
position a little bit because I thought
during the game I had the bishop pair I
have the better Pawn structure also but
his pieces are his pieces can get quite
active quickly actually
um as in the game I played Bishop G5
let's say which I was not so happy about
why not because
um well in the game he played H6 but
actually I was a bit more afraid of
Queen A5 here
which I hadn't really checked too well
yeah so Queen D2 was like it's like a
normal move let's say but Knight E4 was
the problem and after Knight takes E4
Queen takes D2 I is the move that I
missed and I cannot take with a knight
because Rook takes E2 so you don't have
a good way of care and Bishop takes Z2
there's Rook takes E4 and problem is I
cannot go to D3 to defend the C4 Pawn
because Rook D4 yeah it's unfortunate
actually yeah very yeah but uh yeah
Queen A5 was a bit uh an annoying way to
kind of discordinate my pieces somehow
do you have to go back maybe yeah
exactly yeah this also when I we spoke
after the game he said that Bishop D2
was the move that he didn't really like
but still maybe you can make some move
like I did well I don't know for pizza
you can go to a better Square maybe like
B6 and then you need to calculate
options like Knight D5 also of course
but uh still like Bishop D2 was not
really a move that I I was saying like
this yeah exactly yeah it's getting very
sharp yeah and this is not something I
wanted to calculate because it looks
like a very nice positional Advantage
Bishops and so why not just Bishop B3
then yeah well in hindsight okay I would
have played this okay but actually it
was nice in the game because he went H6
and now I went to E3 and somehow the H6
bonuses are like I can go Queen D2 with
Tempo let's say and the pawn is a bit
weak actually you ended up winning this
Pawn at the end uh yeah exactly exactly
that's what Bishop G5 I got some useful
so 94. yeah
um yeah Knight E4 well good move of
course
um if I were to take on e4 and Rook
takes E4 I don't really know like uh
what my
plan is here like how do I put my pieces
because if Queen D2 then Queen H4 and
some Rook E8 some Knight D4 someday it
can get get a bit annoying I just please
play you can get even some attack at
some point and my pieces are not um
they're a bit cramped up and I cannot
move very freely so Knight D5 was a kind
of an attempt to
well well just say I have a strong night
and I keep some pieces on the board
he took B2 which I thought was not a
good move actually
I was happy to see this I was more like
well I think you should have made maybe
some queen move here well I thought so
during the game um like Queen A5 for
example and I don't really know what to
do
it's hard to find a good move for me
so your Pawn is your Pawn is oh maybe
it's not really necessarily hanging but
um like he can just go rookie E8 with
other rook and like in worst case go
back with the queen and he has like uh
all these pieces are perfectly placed
and I don't really know what to play
because Queen C2 if I were to go
somewhere the Knight D4 is always an
issue yeah you don't want to give up one
of your pictures exactly I don't want to
give up especially my dark squared
Bishop
[Music]
um
yeah so maybe this was something to
think about if I were to go Rook B1
let's say that maybe rookie eight like
maybe
yeah exactly and the rugby one there's
Queen takes eight uh no not Queen takes
A3 sorry but then um A3 is hanging like
later in some lines
for example Knight C3 somewhere also an
option even like and I have to calculate
already
it's very tough
um yeah but the good thing is to say six
Pawn hangs in all those lines yeah so I
got this nice
okay yeah then you write it took B2 Rook
B1 and here he went back I was thinking
like Knight C3 I was calculating
actually because first I thought I was
winning instantly with Queen D2 but I
forgot that he can take E2 with check
actually okay and okay position is like
nothing special yeah
really
it still feels Pleasant for you somehow
very very but I can also um just take C3
and then B7 and I have a bishop pair
instead of going into this right I can
just um take C3 and B7
yeah exactly because uh I can even
choose which one I take but I think B7
is better
just to break apart the pawns and like
give some ideas black exchange some
pieces this way at least maybe he can
try hanging on but
I'm not sure
okay so instead he went back and you
were happy with this because of the
bishop parent yeah well he kind of just
gave me like um he gave me like easy
play because before my pieces were a bit
cramped up and yet he was playing with
activity in Knight E4 opening the
diagonal of his Bishop
but now he activated my Rook actually so
all my beasts are kind of doing
something and coordinating and here he
played Rook B8
well the thing is I want to I would like
to play Rook C7 here but the problem is
that it fails tactically due to Knight
C3 so I have to take I think or I don't
have to but I I was relying on my next
move actually it was a very nice move
for forcing a black to play F5 and
weaken his structure because if Rook E5
there's Bishop F4 and if rookie 8 Bishop
D7
this is very annoying and so he has to
block with the pawn actually
yeah once your pieces come into a game
actually calculated instead of Bishop F3
also Knight F4 and some very complex
lines with black has strong move inter
Metal Knight C3 now I think
and some Queen F3 stuff there's Knight
E5 always so it's not really working my
gosh oh yeah yeah it's very um
oh your queen doesn't have a square yeah
exactly it's very unfortunate
for this Knight T3 because otherwise
Knight F4 is interesting I think yeah
this is yeah exactly yeah it's
unfortunate okay so Bishop F3 King H7
Queen A4 so this is all very comfortable
for you yeah 95 is not the best move I
think also I thought Queen B7 during the
game
it's uh it gets also like black would
like to play Knight D4 here but the
problem is um I can capture this and
queen D7 check I win The Rook yeah
so therefore Queen B7 was maybe a good
idea I'm not sure once again but uh
if you want we can
we can with yeah after Knight E5 it's
well fairly easy I think yeah because
this Pawn structure changes just so nice
for you yeah I don't even have to take
A7 but
you know it's bad for your opponent when
you don't have to take a free Pawn yeah
yeah exactly but uh okay
took
and play King h8 best move
here I went for Knight F4 I thought it
was better than the computer give
section I thought it was like
they don't have A4
yeah well Knight F4 I just played
because I saw a concrete tactical
variation as in the game right but I
think I think this line that you went
for this is well he had to play Knight
E5 I think only chance but it's still
yeah but I think it's still like from
practical point of view my opponent was
also in time trouble so it's very
difficult to defend this
I think
I can just run the a pawn of the board
and he needs to figure out something
smart like really quickly which is not
easy with limited time on the clock yeah
it's actually hard to say how to stop
the spawn
pawn and also you still have this some
nights yeah exactly I still don't see it
to be honest but uh yeah yeah that's
somehow but
yeah and after that I cannot take with a
rook of course because E3 it's a nasty
trick but yeah I can still take with a
bishop somehow but yeah this is the idea
no but but this is something no reason
to go into this yeah I must be happy
about this I think like this end game
that you got
with Bishop versus knight you must have
been very happy here yeah I think it's
just completely winning uh I paid Rook
C7 somehow to force D5 yeah D5 not the
most accurate necessarily but I just
didn't want some Rook A5 stuff yeah but
with no time for him if I think he had
to play and now with the Rook
disconnected yeah this is just a strong
right and I think you're okay H3 yeah
and here he just I think this is winning
basically by force like if I calculate
as well Bishop E3 a controlling D4 yeah
and here I calculated basically until
the end of the game almost because it's
all really like uh yeah this his only
idea is to try to kick my Bishop off and
go for D4 but the problem is I have best
pawns on the side of the board from both
sides basically yeah so I'll get past H
Pawn and past a pawn and the Knight is
very bad against sponsor
a or H bonds basically yeah that's kind
of useless disciplesh yeah it's from
both sides that's the problem yeah
so
um
yeah now H4 yeah
yeah and at the end the night was even
against one time the night is pretty
useless
the king is just too far away that's the
problem I think what's up until this
point and yeah I'm winning the night
okay so this is where the game three
yeah very nice Victory by you I I do are
you a student in one of the U.S
universities or I'm not I know I'm not
the student oh you're not assistant High
School oh you're a high school student
okay are you looking to be recruited to
University or no
but sure yet uh I'll just see how it
just goes first and then we'll see I
guess okay well uh thank you so much for
joining us and good luck in the rest of
your game so we hope to see you back
here thanks for having me